Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two
lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the brown
table of dim lighting,
We're taking you on a
journey that we've been
on for many months,
this culminated in this,
I was going to say huge TikTok project,
but basically it's... in our minds,
We've put a lot of energy into this thing.
That's just come out.
Don't oversell it.
We know how it went.
This past Friday. But, yeah.
As of the recording of this,
we haven't experienced what
you have now experienced,
which is watching our, we,
we've been calling it Hazel.
That's what we call the project.
Yeah.
Our Hazel TikTok...
Our multi project, multipart
one night scripted...
horror comedy series.
Yeah.
I know, when you're dealing
with these new mediums,
you don't know exactly
how to, to describe it,
but what we will say,
if you are listening right now,
They are.
And you did not already watch
what we're talking about,
because you're like, you
didn't know about it,
or you're like, I don't
do to TikTok thing.
It will be more of an
enjoyable experience for you.
If you drop what you're doing
and take the time to watch it.
Even if you're not a TikTok person.
Now, at some point, we
are going to post it on,
depending on when you're
listening to this,
it will be on our,
the Rhett and Link YouTube
channel at some point,
just in its full form.
Which will make it
easier if you don't want
to use, you know, the TikTok app.
But anyway,
we just suggest that you
go over and watch it.
I dunno. It's a little...
We're going to be talking about it so,
you need to have a little...
It's a little over like
20 minutes of your time
that you would have to devote to the full,
the full experience and that
it would just be helpful
to then come back and be able to hear the,
the discussion about it.
I use the term ambitious
in, in the creative realm.
It's something that, like, we can get
into all the reasons
why we decided to do it.
There's a number of itches
that we wanted to scratch.
And boy, I really want to
know what people think.
We can talk about the anticipation.
That's another part of
this that has been so fun.
But another thing we want to talk about,
kinda, a larger conversation
than just the Hazel project
is our relationship with TikTok.
Mhm.
And, you know, having come up on YouTube,
having 15 years of
figuring out how to take
what we want to do and translate it
into the particular platforms where we
can get traction and
where there's audience,
and then the advent of
TikTok and figuring out
well, what's, what does
mythical on TikTok mean?
Yeah.
What are the opportunities there?
We've been through a lot of
challenges as we tried to figure that out.
So I think that, in and of itself,
can, can be a fun conversation.
So, if you're an avid
TikToker or watcher of TikTok,
or if you have nothing to do with it,
I think there's going to be
touch points for all of us to,
to figure out how we
interface with that platform.
Because you may find yourself,
you might be, I think
this is our tendency,
maybe just because of our age,
it's just like when a new social
media platform comes along,
you just are like,
"Uh, really? Like, this is the thing now?
Like, am I going to
have to get an account?"
And then at some point,
based on your personality,
your disposition, and the way
that you divide your time,
there's a point, there's a threshold
for most people in
which they either decide
to swear it off and never join,
or they finally give in and join.
And I think that as middle aged creators,
there's an interesting, with
kids who enjoy this medium,
it's sort of an interesting
conversation around
how do you make a decision
to actually go for it?
Why do you do it? What's your approach?
What are you learning? What
are you trying to accomplish?
Right.
But let's start with
this, the idea for Hazel,
and kind of what was, what was behind it?
What set the stage in your recollection?
Because it was, it was many months ago.
Yeah, well.
It wasn't first, like
let's do something for,
let's do something scary.
Do something for Halloween.
There was something, there,
there was conversation that
was going on in the background.
Which is, as we've established,
And we actually did a whole episode
about it earlier this year,
where we, we talked about
all the other things
that we have worked on,
that you've never seen because it's...
Their ideas that are developed
for television or movies.
That is a whole different process outside
of the digital media that
we kind of own and control,
which is the thing that
you're watching right now.
Which, we don't have to ask
permission to make this podcast.
No one has to approve it.
So, those things where
you're writing scripts
and trying to get traditional
stuff out the ground,
it's there, it's a long time coming
and then it may never show up.
No one may ever see it.
And that's very frustrating for us.
There's so much, even right now,
like even, just so you know, right now,
we're in the midst of working on a couple
of very exciting projects.
I'll just go ahead and
say, one's a, I mean,
we've got multiple TV
shows that we've tried
to get off the ground and continue to try
to get off the ground, but there's a,
another pilot that we have completed.
And now there's a, a feature script,
a whole movie that we are
beginning to, to write.
And so, these are things
that we are passionate about
and their, it's a fun process.
And we throw ourselves creatively
at them and hopefully one,
or multiple of them,
will be able to be made.
And I think when you look at the,
sort of the pie chart of our
time, when you wonder, like,
what do Rhett and Link do?
Like, well, what do they do besides
the things that I see them do?
Mhm.
There's a big piece of the pie.
That's like doesn't result
in things that you see.
So, because that's,
it's frustrating, right?
At least yet.
It's frustrating to kind of
pour yourself into something.
So then, the conversation
sort of shifted to a place
where it's like, okay, yes.
We've got all this
stuff we're trying to do
that may never get seen.
We've got all this
stuff that we already do
that does get seen on a regular basis,
but is there an in-between?
Can we put one more thing on our plate,
which is the in-between,
which is stuff that has a high,
sort of creative, experimental quotient.
Trying something new that
is more narrative maybe
in, in, in, in its description.
Is there another, is there
a place for us to do that?
Yeah, because we're developing
this narrative content.
Yeah.
How do we do some of that,
that people can actually see?
And also do it in a very self-contained,
frankly cheap way that doesn't take a lot
of our time and doesn't
take a lot of money.
So.
And, also, then is structured
so that it makes us part
of a different conversation.
Yeah.
You know, if you're,
if you're an avid
listener of Ear Biscuits,
if you're a, a dedicated viewer
of Good Mythical Morning,
if you're a fan of
Mythical Kitchen, you can,
you can get involved in those worlds
and just kind of stay there.
We're grappling with the
challenge of continuing
to find ways to reach out
and introduce more people
to the world of mythical and
the things that we're doing.
People have an idea of what,
and an awareness of good mythical morning,
and they might, may dip in and out of it.
But, we also want to
do things that continue
to remind people.
Hey, we're, we've still
got ideas and we want to,
we want to make things
that express ourselves
and also make us part of new conversations
and introduce us to new mythical beasts.
And I think above all it's
for, for both of us, it's,
there's a creative passion,
to that we don't want to, cause, again.
You don't want to sit on your hands,
You don't want to sit on your laurel.
Rest on your laurels.
Yes, we're the guys who eat weird things
on the internet and do things.
And you kind of see us in the
context of our friendship.
Maybe that could be enough
for a lot of people, you know,
for us, I don't think
it is because it's like,
we got things that we want to create.
We got worlds that we want to bring up.
So, then the discussion started was like,
what does that look
like? Because we've had,
we've had a number of people,
including like TV executives
who say things like, guys,
if you have an idea for something,
why don't you just make it
and put it on YouTube? Right.
And I think there's a number of reasons
why we've been hesitant to do that
when it comes to narrative stuff,
besides just like an
occasional sketch or whatever,
which we're not really doing
that much on YouTube anymore.
The reason being...
But we are doing it on TikTok,
and we'll talk about that later.
Yeah. The reason being is
that with few exceptions,
people are not really interacting
with narrative content on,
on YouTube, in, in a meaningful way.
Right? And you can be like, well,
you guys could change that,
but it's like, that's a,
a tough hill to climb.
What we were seeing is
that, you know what?
Kind of in an early sort
of YouTube way, the,
the, this early stage of TikTok,
one of the things that's
happening is sketch comedy,
just to use a broad term,
has sort of found a
resurgence in this place.
Like, scripted comedy
has found a home on TikTok,
and all of a sudden people are engaged.
Our kids, are engaging with it in a way
that they are not engaging with YouTube.
In a way that's much more
broad than if you were to apply
that same statement of
sketch comedy to Vine,
back in the day.
Yeah.
I never observed, maybe I missed it,
because we never got
on the vine bandwagon.
I never observed a type of
sketch that I wanted to do.
It was, it was, it was very
short and very tonally specific.
And there's a, there's a
broad range of content.
I mean, there's, there's all,
all niches now seem to exist on TikTok.
I mean, spiritual deconstruction,
TikTok, as an example,
And Christian TikTok.
Oh yeah.
I mean, you name it, that
it, it's all happening there.
And so there's like,
it can melt into the world of podcasting
and it can melt into the
world of sketch comedy.
It can melt into the, of
course, the world of dance.
Well, and, and, I, and I was doing some.
And avant-guarde shit.
So, all types of stuff.
I don't remember... So, I
always kind of think, I was,
I was sitting there trying
to figure out like, okay.
Is there a way in for us that
kind of makes it, I mean,
honestly it was kind of,
it was from a strategy
standpoint in terms of, yeah,
we could do something that was,
is just like just straight up comedy,
like classic Rhett and Link
sketch in a narrative fashion,
as you see. And we'll talk about later,
we are doing classic Rhett and Link sketch
sort of individually on TikTok
and learning a lot over
there, but like, how do you,
we want to do something
that's more eventized
and get people to kind
of, kind of draw it in.
I think kind of separately from that,
I just happened to, because I tend to,
I'm personally interested
in horror, right?
I'm a horror fan and I kind of keep up
with what's happening in that world.
But typically it's just movies.
I watched horror movies
and then I'll watch
some horror TV shows,
but mostly horror movies.
And I saw this article
about horror TikTok,
Mhm.
But it was also like horror
TikTok, horror Instagram.
And what I saw is that,
okay, first of all,
there's also like, there's that,
I don't know if you remember
a couple of years ago,
there was maybe just a year ago,
there was a Twitter thread
where it was a writer
who said, who said that
they were going to a cabin
in the woods to, to write a movie.
Mhm.
And they were like, oh,
there's something making noise outside.
And it was a Twitter thread.
It turns out that the whole
thing, from the beginning
was designed to be, it was,
it was designed to become a
movie or designed to be a story.
It was all, it was all made
up to begin with. And...
It was, it was narrative.
It was an, it was a narrative.
And I don't know if that one,
But they kind of tricked you.
I don't know if that one
ended up becoming something,
but there's been multiple Twitter threads,
not just horror Twitter
threads, but Instagram things.
And now TikTok stuff that is
either it's intended to live
there first and then
become something bigger.
But then on TikTok, what I was seeing,
is that a lot of people were doing,
there's like this one kid who did...
I use kid, like a teenager.
Did a thing last year
where they had like some,
they were acting like
something was going on
in their neighborhood.
Like their neighborhood was
abandoned or there was some.
And it was like, oh, once a day,
he would kind of do like an update.
And it was like, kind of creepy,
but it was like a once
a day thing for a while.
And you're like, is this real?
Is this not real? Kind
of walking that line.
But the thing that no one had done
is something that's more like a series.
Like some people had done, like,
here's one really creepy video.
And this is what I do on my
channel. But it was like, oh,
is there like a self-contained
multipart series
that happens over the course
of a shorter time span?
That actually feels like it's
happening in the platform.
Like, it feels like, oh,
this is not taking something that was made
for something else and
putting it on TikTok,
but it's, if someone were to do a,
horror, if something were
to happen to somebody
that was a horrific on TikTok,
and they were to post it,
what would that look like?
And that's what kind of
opened up the conversation
about the specifics of Hazel.
You just said, what if
something were to happen?
Like a horrific, like you
just made horrific a noun.
Like a horrific thing.
That's what, no, I think
that's what this is, is.
It's a horrific.
This is a horrific.
It's a terrific, horror TikTok
Well, it's a horrif... It's a HorrifTok.
HorrificTok.
Ohh, that's what we're...
It's a HorrificTok
That we're contributing to the genre.
That we've helped... pioneer.
HorrificTok.
Because it's fiction?
TikTok, horror, and...
Fantastic? No...
No, I'm just putting
together horrific and TikTok.
HorrificTok. Yeah.
Yeah. That's good. That works.
Well, let's coin it.
It, we got to get better at saying it.
I've got it. Horrift, HorrificTok.
HorrificTok.
It's just horrific and then Tok.
Horrif...
Horrific and then Tok.
Horrific...Tok.
HorrificTok.
You can say it that way.
Horrific... TikTok.
HorrificTok, HorrificTok,
HorrificTok, HorrificTok
We'll do that on our own time.
HorrificTok.
Okay. I think I have it.
And so, yeah, we were like, okay,
if we do this,
we can have fun with our audience.
We can, we can do something
to where we're gonna,
we're going to trick them.
We're gonna set up this
conceit of it being...
We're going to write,
record, produce a song.
This is something that
like I remember back
when live streaming first started
and Ustream was the
platform that we picked.
And we, we started doing
the Rhett and Link cast
live every Thursday night.
Another thing that we would do,
cause we just wanted to
experiment with the new tool,
was we would do office hours where on,
I think it was on Friday afternoons.
We would just broadcast and
whatever we were working on,
we would explain to whoever
wanted to peep into it.
And then sometimes we would write songs
and we would get input from people
in the chat room and it would,
it would, impact what we were writing on.
This is 2008.
So, that kind of fed into
this idea of we're going
to set the groundwork
of it being something
that's, that's interactive,
um, and unscripted,
and we're just pulling an all nighter.
Yep.
That will be fun to experiment with.
And then it will go into this place
where, we're taking people by surprise
and things are getting scary and it's,
it's a scripted, horrific TikTok...
It's a horrific Tok.
A horrific, HorrificTok.
HorrificTok.
Yeah.
And we were like...
You'll get it.
And I think people will talk about this.
Well, hopefully, people
will talk about it.
That's the really, so that's the,
We're going to get into talking
about sort of the process,
but that's the really
interesting thing about recording
this podcast right now.
We're recording it
before it gets released.
There's been so much conversation around.
Right.
I mean, are we doing something?
Is this stupid? Like, hey,
are we completely missing the point?
Is this going to flop?
I think it's 11 parts.
I can't, I can't remember
exactly where we.
Yeah.
Massaged it, a little.
It was 13 at one point. And it was 12.
I think it's on 11. I think we...
Doing that many videos over the course
of a couple of hours on TikTok, like,
are we like, just directly
violating some principle
of the platform, shooting
ourselves in the foot?
Are people going to be like,
what are these guys thinking?
I don't know where to start.
Like, is it technically going
to work, like there's...
It could be a total disaster Tok.
Yeah, this could be...
DisastTok.
This could be,
I'm not going to say it's
going to be a mistake.
I mean, what do we really have to lose?
But like, while we're talking about this
or while you're listening to this,
it could be that like, yeah,
that it didn't work and no one cared.
Yeah.
Which we're prepared for.
Are we?
Or it could be...
I'm not prepared for it emotionally.
Of course not. It was like, oh,
I get what you guys were going
for. And I appreciate it.
And like it, and I want
more stuff like this,
or it will lead to something
else in this world or beyond.
Who knows?
We're talking about it in
complete ignorance at this point.
We've done enough things to know
that once you put something out there,
sometimes it immediately becomes clear
that there's one thing that
seems blatantly obvious
now that we didn't think of.
Yeah.
And I, and I do think we've
thought enough about it
to know that this could
just not work on TikTok.
Mhm.
Logistically, experientially,
like from a user standpoint.
And the main, my main concern,
I'll just speak out loud at this point.
Is that, as you'll see, when you watch it,
as you have already seen,
because you stopped and
you went and watched it.
Um, and hopefully we've
made it easy for you to,
I think we've, we've put the...
It's too late to even say that.
They've already done it. Right?
We've put the series...
What, why are you even saying this?
You can click on the, so you
can watch it all in order.
That's important. We've
labeled the parts anyway.
See, you're still, you're
still actually trying
to plan it. It's done.
And we also, I have a lot
of trauma over this whole,
like multi-part thing and
getting people to watch things
in order with a whole GMM 22 thing.
Yeah.
Because of the complete flop.
So, anyway.
Um, anyway, the, if you start at part 1,
part 1, in and of itself,
is not this giant,
clickable, optimized TikTok, right?
Yeah.
Like we're, we're putting
all this stuff on TikTok, so.
It's designed to be unassuming,
so there's not this huge funnel.
It's designed so that,
once shit gets weird...
And you know, crows
start dive, bombing the,
the glass door and then
you find yourself passing
through a door in our creative house,
into the woods in a very
realistic transition,
like a totally hidden transition
that we can talk about.
Um, it, when it gets real...
That's when it begins to matter.
Then people, people start to care
and then we're counting on them,
figuring out how to go back to
the beginning and figure out
whoa, now, what have I missed?
How did this, how did they,
how did this start happening?
Yeah.
Why is this backwards walking,
backwards singing, creepy woman,
uh, abducting Link...
Yeah.
And taking him into a forest.
Cause that's the, so the one thing,
if I could, if, if the,
if this didn't work, and I'm
going to pin it on something,
one of the things I
could pin it on would be,
oh, you know what?
The first part should have had the,
the trappings of a viral TikTok.
Which is actually something that
when we wrote this months ago,
we actually did not know TikTok
nearly as well as we do now,
having thrown so much stuff up there
and learned all these lessons.
Right.
So I'm like, oh man.
So we started with the, we're sitting down
to write a song, write it with us.
That's not something that
people are going to be like,
"Hey, tune into Rhett and Links channel.
They're writing a song with us!"
Yeah. That's just, I mean,
The entry point.
For mythical beast they'll be excited...
Yeah.
But it's not going to be something
that I think will get the
attention of anybody else. So.
But, what could that,
what could that have been?
It's a huge risk.
Because, the other thing we wanted to do,
is we wanted to make sure that it,
we needed to bring you into a real place.
So, it didn't need to start as a sketch.
It was important that it started as a,
"Oh Rhett and Link are
actually doing this.
The Rhett and Link, that I know,
are doing something in real
life that is believable."
So when we began to introduce
the unbelievable elements,
we sort of brought you along,
and we've got you in
this place where you can
be emotionally manipulated
for entertainment purposes.
And this is one of the things that
I immediately got super excited about
that, I think, fueled our energy
through the entire project.
So, let's get into that after a quick ad.
A quick ad.
Check out this pin.
♪ I've got it on my sweater, ♪
♪ You can put it on your jacket, ♪
♪ You can put it on anything, ♪
♪ And it spins. ♪
It's the, it's the Wheel of Mythicality.
And it is a pin.
It says, "It's time to spin
the Wheel of Mythicality."
You can get one of these at Mythical.com.
It's nice.
You can get two of them and put 'em
strategically over your nips.
Don't put them in your nips, though.
Don't, unless you have
an existing piercing.
That would be cool.
Jen is like, "No, no, do
not give that advice."
Jen is saying...
If you have a nipple piercing,
you probably already know what you can
and shouldn't do to it.
I mean.
Maybe you can put other things in there.
It doesn't, it doesn't
have one thing that,
it has two individual things,
so you've got to pierce twice.
You, you, you'd have to take the rod,
that's going sideways through your nipple,
and create a new thing
for the pin to grab on to.
So that, the thing that's
going through your nipple,
is the thing that's always
going through your nipple.
And the thing that you're
adding to the piercing,
is our thing.
Don't put our thing in your nipple.
Keep your thing in your nipple,
then put our thing on the
thing that's in your nipple.
And everybody will be okay.
But it is made for the nipples indirectly.
It is made for all nipples.
Hey, this is what you get
with the video version.
You get an unhinged
nipple ad for Mythical.com
and you also get clarity about Hazel
because now, the assembled version
Yeah.
Is live on YouTube and skip over
to the Rhett and Link channel.
So, if for some reason...
And you can, you can
watch it all together.
You have resisted...
Not on TikTok.
Up until this point, you've
resisted going over to TikTok,
with a multiple urgings
that we have given.
Now just go to our, go to
the Rhett and Link channel
and watch the whole thing,
and then come back and you'll enjoy
this discussion even more.
You know what time it is.
The thing that I got
so excited about that,
you know, there's a point in every,
I get goosebumps now thinking
about it, you get this.
I always look for the spark at the,
at the genesis of a creative idea.
A lot of times you're bringing
something to the table.
You're a take, make
something out of nothing.
And I'm more of take that
something and shaping it
into even more of a thing
that's really gonna work.
So, I find that my
interactions, a lot of times
are learning how to...
Not filter any your pitches,
but, um, champion the things that,
that I think are working like,
where we get this energy.
And for this one, it
really was the, you know,
we were on the same page
about what we wanted to accomplish.
But when we started talking
about the experience
that we could give to our audience
and it'd be this special surprise...
That we could, you know,
we, we pretaped it.
We've made it seem like we're
doing it, basically live.
Filming a little something, postin' it,
and making it happen in real time.
Of course, you know,
we filmed it freaking months in advance.
So we can, we have the luxury
and the privilege of like
having a front row seat
to what happens...
Mhm, yeah.
On TikTok.
You know, like, seeing
the comments come in,
seeing over the course of
that 2nd, and 3rd post,
4th post.
People starting to realize,
"Hold on, this is not
what I thought it was."
We're not going to be writing
a song. This is crazy.
This is scripted. This is,
this is a horror comedy thing,
and I'm, I just have,
have been very excited about
observing that experience
and observing it as an
experiment in real time.
It kind of...
As an experiment.
In real time.
Like, how are people going to respond?
As it happens.
How, how are Mythical Beasts
going to band together
and be commenting on the
Mythical Society Discord,
on, uh, Twitter, obviously on TikTok,
but forming these ad hoc viewing parties
where you're waiting for the next post.
Because it is a special
experience for people
who are watching in real time.
And we had this challenge
of promoting it and saying,
this is something we're excited
about. It should be fun.
But also downplaying it
as something that's just
an interactive, song writing.
Having to say, having to say,
"You're going to write a song with us."
And so it's like, if that
didn't appeal to you...
You're, you may be out.
You're, you're definitely...
"I'm not going to get a
TikTok account for that.
If I don't already have one."
But there's this,
there's this real time experience
with the people that want
to be there and are able to
be there as it's unfolding.
Yeah.
And they're making sense of
it was very exciting to me.
And then there's this TikTok experiment
of getting TikTok viewers
who are not first mythical
beast coming into it
and seeing if we're right,
that they'll figure it out
and they'll be into it even
if they don't care about us. And then...
Yeah, yeah, who knows, man,
putting it somewhere else
and seeing if it can develop,
if, if people will enjoy it off-platform
and on the Rhett and Link YouTube channel.
Well, I'll say again,
one of the theories from the
marketing side of this thing,
and it, did this work? I don't know.
Is that, okay.
It's one thing to just make
another horror movie, right?
When you make another horror movie,
you are competing with everyone
who's ever made horror
movies and everyone who
is currently making horror movies
and releasing horror movies.
Uh, you're subject to
critical response, et cetera,
marketing budget. Now,
with, when you do some of.
And the expectations
that everyone approaches
any horror movie with.
But when you do something
on a platform like TikTok,
I mean, I always talk
about how I feel like
the only reason that we're actual...
"successful" in quotes,
comedians, you define that how you will.
We make a living doing it.
We make a living.
Is because we came up through
the Christian comedy world.
I'm just going to be frank about it.
Like if, if you had a...
We were funny in settings where
people didn't require you,
or expect, or demand you to be hilarious.
We kinda gamed...
The bar was lower.
We gamed the system a
little bit by developing
in this bubble and a place where
we weren't competing
against any other comedians.
We were competing against like,
maybe a funny worship leader,
which is an easy target.
And because we know that,
that's one of the reasons,
maybe the root reason why we
have a chip on our shoulder.
There's other reasons now
in how people view YouTubers
and creators versus
traditional celebrities.
But we don't have to get into any of that.
And, so, there is this belief that
if you do something like this,
on a platform like TikTok
at a time in the evolution of
the platform, like right now,
there's a possibility that
just having made the decision
to do something that is this
ambitious, and involved,
in this genre that people care about,
maybe, okay, did we make,
did we make, Get Out?
Hell no, we did something that
we shot in two nights, right?
It, we didn't make it.
We're not, we wouldn't be capable.
I'm not saying we would,
you could give us all
the money in the world.
I'm not saying we're going
to make a Jordan Peele movie,
but we don't have to.
We need to make something
that people are like,
"That's cool.
I was scared when I needed to be scared,
I laugh when you guys wanted me to laugh,
and you did something in a place
that I wasn't expecting it.
And so now, I'm actually talking about it,
because you made the
decision to put it here."
There's a secret hope
that that will be part
of the strategy.
Yep.
Now, the specific, the
specifics of the idea.
I mean, it's a...
We were having a
conversation at some point
where it was like, Hey, what if,
what if it had something
to do with an album?
You know, oh, that we could
make it where we're at,
where we're starting the night singing,
and then, the, the specifics,
it's not like there's some
groundbreaking plot, right?
This is a, if you want
to be honest about it,
the specifics of the way that this plot,
sort of unfolds is like,
yes, it's an intact,
interesting... Uh, way
of getting a, getting your antagonist,
your monster into your house.
This is a "monster in the house
movie," to use that genre.
We needed a way to do it.
Like the ring, where the
girl climbs out through
the television, when you, when you play
a certain whatever it was.
That was like a, a VHS tape.
You made me watch it,
and I've tried to wipe it
from my memory ever since.
So it had, so yeah, it
had that sort of like,
there's a vehicle in which
this person can get brought
into your world.
And that's where the whole
Hazel thing came from
in the Hazel making of it all.
Like, we, we talked
before about how we're...
And I especially since I
watch a lot of horror movies,
very scared of, especially
like a little girl in a dress,
like the, the Poltergeist deal.
That's just something that is always
kind of freaking me out.
Yeah.
Because you got this mix
of what you perceived
to be innocent.
Now, there's this sinister side to it.
And that's the classic horror trope.
So it was like, okay,
how could we make this,
like a woman in a dress?
And then how do you go?
What kind of music would you, oh,
maybe something like appalachian.
And it just, so.
Something that's haunting,
but not, that doesn't read
as horror immediately.
It's like horror adjacent. Like if you,
if you have the right
album cover and you right,
have the right song, which
we tried to create, you know?
Yeah. We were, we were
leveraging the fact that,
like I have a record collection
at the creative house.
It's true to us. We've
made records in the past.
So, we know, knew that we had
our, our team can make of,
Can make a vinyl.
Knew how to make a record
and like actually making
a record that plays,
and that has high quality
packaging is a great way to, to,
to suck people into the story
when they still don't know it's a story.
So, we had those elements
that we felt like
were working for us.
And we started meeting with Derek Ferman,
who produced our vinyl covers and we've,
and works very closely
with my cousin, Britain,
great guy that we vibe
with that, you know,
we started talking to
him about the project
and he was really excited about
the experimental nature of it.
And so we went in there
for a recording session.
We, we, of course we
knew we had to cast the,
we need to have a female voice.
And then we would need to cast
somebody to play that female.
And then Jenna suggested Paige.
Her, you know, who she, who she knew from,
what? Theater? From college.
Kentucky theater.
Uh, uh, right after college, yeah,
Uh, Kentucky Shakespeare.
Kentucky Shakespeare, yeah.
So, you, Jenna was recommending Paige,
because Paige is in a
band. Paige is a vocalist.
And we had worked with Paige
before we even had met,
and started working with
Jenna, which is so strange, so.
We brought Paige in, she recorded the part
for Hazel, nailed it.
And she's also an actor and
can come in and play the part.
So it was like a win-win.
And like, she was already
in the mythical world
because what we had
worked with her on before
is Buddy System season one,
when, let's see, there's the commercial
for the Drain Weaver.
Yeah.
Which is, you know,
our co ex-girlfriend's,
who's now became the media mogul
with Billy May's type products,
including all the hair that
goes into your shower drain.
If you put the right
mold down in, in there,
you can then, after,
an X number of showers,
you can pull that out.
And it will have an article of clothing
that has been magically
woven from your body hair,
and your head hair. All of your hairs.
And we needed a model for the commercial.
And the, the audition process was one
of the more awkward audition processes
that I've ever been a
part of, because it was
bringing in women into our office.
Now.
Where me, you, Stevie,
the casting director.
And it wasn't just the two of us.
And probably a couple of other people.
We were all sitting in our office.
But still.
When you bring a bunch of women,
one at a time into your office,
and the thing that they're
doing for their audition
is acting like they're showering.
And they don't have any lines...
That is, uh...
It gets...
We just, we did not anticipate...
How weird it was gonna feel.
How awkward that could get.
To watch women in our
office pantomime showering.
And then just kind of sit there
and like nod with a note pad.
Like, oh yeah, she touches herself in a...
What?
I mean, it's like, what
do you do when you shower?
You like, you're like touching,
you're, you're bathing
and you're like reacting to the...
Say, "Scrub yourself."
Okay. Well, I mean, but
it wasn't, they were,
they were touching
themselves, not in that way.
Scrubbing themselves.
Like in a shower way.
Bathing themselves.
Anyway, Paige did a great job at that.
Hey, Paige seemed to understand...
She understood the assignment.
Because there was a voice over, like,
"Have you ever thought about
all the hair that you send down
the drain and never make into clothes?"
And then you're like, "Yes."
You know, so there's,
obviously it was very comedic.
So you've got to like, respond
to this voice over artist.
Yeah. She was doing, she was doing the...
She got it.
I'm in an infomercial.
I will say it's been a
long time. So, I mean...
Let's tell this story.
I don't think there's any way
that anyone's going to be
able to trace this back
to this particular person,
because there was no record
of who auditioned that day.
But there was someone who did
not understand the assignment.
Uh, in two ways,
Yeah.
The first way that they did not understand
the assignment is that
this particular woman
thought that she was auditioning
for the role of Amy Brielle's,
which had already been given to Leslie.
Talking about the lead
role in the entire series.
To Leslie Bibb.
And the way we found out was
because when she came in,
she started showering.
She did start shower.
She did.
I don't know how she put
these two things together.
I don't know what script she got ahold of,
but then she, she launches into
a monologue while showering.
Which of course, no one has done,
because they don't have any lines.
And then we realize, she is memorized...
Leslie's line.
And Amy Brielle's monologue.
And we, well, again, we're nice guys.
We're good Southern
boys. So we let her go.
Through the whole thing.
We were like, well, she's going to do it.
Let's just see how well
she's memorized it.
She's prepared.
Maybe we'll recast the lead roll.
I don't know who spoke first to say,
"Ah, great job on that.
That's, um, that was really good.
But actually, this role
is just the shower girl."
So can you do that all again?
Without all the stuff you memorized?
It felt, I felt so bad for
her. And no one else did it.
I mean, I don't think it was on us.
I have to also say that her
wardrobe choice that day...
Well, I'll call it catsuit.
It was a, it, it was
what you might expect.
If you, if you thought like, oh,
this is a shower scene in
like a different genre.
Maybe, you know.
Yeah, like. If you were going
to be nude in the shower
and you wanted to...
But you didn't want, you
didn't want your audition
to be nude, but you wanted it to be like,
but, just so you will know what
I look like without clothes
on, I'm wearing clothes
that will allow you to come
to those conclusions.
There's a suit for that.
And she had it all.
There, there, there is
an article of clothing
and she had that on.
It was just very tight
in every single place.
And it gave the, I guess it's what, uh...
We did learn a lot.
You would wear if you
were going to be naked.
I don't know.
And the more I think about
it, it was a strategic choice.
Not knowing where, where it could go.
Yep, that's true.
She didn't get the part. Paige, did.
Long story. Paige got the part.
It's wild that, like, Jenna knew Paige
from way back when, then we met Paige,
then we met Jenna and then
Jenna reminded us of Paige.
And then Paige comes in
and like had a great time.
Yeah.
Again, it was weird
because like, it's Paige's,
vocals as Hazel, but then
we never see her face.
It's like, we're giving
her this limitation.
Like whenever we cast you
in something for either,
you're not going to talk at
all, or you're going to sing,
but we're never going to see
your face, but it is Paige.
It is.
It's the back of her head.
And she did an excellent
job. And if you know.
One day we might put it together.
She might have lines and a face.
We're not making choices
about not giving her lines or give,
giving her face time because
of anything about her.
It's just, she happens to
be involved in the projects
where that happens to be the case.
One interesting thing
about that and about,
about Paige is that,
of course, she was the focal point
of all, of a lot of the
horror, you know, you,
and we knew that we had this
idea about the backmasking
of playing it back,
playing the record backwards
is the way that sort
of the portal opens up.
And that plays into these
sort of childhood fears.
And, and some of the stuff that we said,
I don't actually remember
a guy coming to our church
to talk about it.
But I think there was maybe
something that Campbell
at one point.
He came to Campbell, yeah.
And he talked about backmasking
and of course we believed
everything that anybody said
to us when we were kids,
especially in a Christian context.
So we were like, yeah, I guess the devil
is influencing Led Zeppelin to send
messages through the records backwards.
It was a seminar that
I think he'd been doing
for over a decade by that point.
Yeah.
And it's like, but we were
still, like, mesmerized.
So in that tends to be, and
first of all, backwards,
singing and talking is unsettling
for deep biological reasons, I guess.
And it's, so, it's, it
is a very scary thing.
So, we were like, do you
take this backwards...
Deep biological reasons?
I'm just saying that there's,
you're intrinsically scared
of backwards talking.
It's just weird. And
you know, you, you, you,
you put it in the context
of this dark house
with this woman singing.
And then we knew, oh...
It's a threat.
She's singing backwards. Let's
have her walking backwards.
And then, I think this is a good time
to talk about Ben's involvement in it.
So, Ben Eck, who works for us has worked
for us for a very long time.
The only person that has
worked here longer is Stevie.
Cause this is the first
person that Stevie helped
us hire back for The Mythical Show.
But Ben only worked for us
like a week less than Steve.
Yeah, yeah.
Cause.
Very, very soon after.
Stevie and Ben had worked at together
at, at a previous job.
So then, she was like, this
is a guy I'm bringing in.
Yeah.
And, um, yeah, he's been, I mean, he's,
he's instrumental on the
Mythical Kitchen side now,
you'll hear Josh and
the team talking to Ben.
Yeah.
But when we have ideas
like this, because Ben,
Ben was there for all those
classic sketches, music videos,
he was there for buddy system.
He understands what we're
trying to get across creatively
and narratively, which again,
we don't do a whole lot of that
except writing and pitching
at this point. So the making
of the narrative stuff,
it was like, all right, well,
let's bring Ben back into this process
and get him really
involved. He's going to,
he's going to be essentially
directing this, uh,
cause we're going to be
in it the whole time. So.
And he was essential.
Yeah.
As the director.
And then I think the thing about Ben,
because he does have a lot of
filmmaking experience is that,
you know, when he took a look
at the script, it was like,
"Hey, here's my ideas for
the places that we could up
the, the, you know,
this is my idea for how
we could capture this
to make it even scarier.
This is, you know."
Were there even crow's hitting
the window before he got ahold of it?
Yeah.
There was, but there was a lot of,
he had a lot of thought on how to do that
and how to achieve it.
Ben's, Ben's, biggest, uh...
Thing that he brings to the table
that we don't typically
think about is the,
until we get into it is the,
you've got this idea
and you've written it.
How do you capture it visually in a way
that will communicate
what you actually want
to communicate to your audience?
And especially in the
horror genre, which again...
Right.
I've, I've watched a lot of horror movies
and have a sense of what
make of the types of themes,
and visuals, and ideas
that make people scared,
but translating that into,
and this is how, so in other words,
so one of the ideas we had was we want her
to always be walking backwards,
but Ben was able to
literally do a test shoot
where he's like the way
to make this super creepy
is to put her dress on backwards
and to have her long stringy hair,
which is not her hair, it's
a wig, in front of her face.
So she looks like she's
facing away, but her arms are,
there's a little, it's a little off.
And then when she moves
towards you it's even freakier
because her legs are moving
in a way as if she was walking
normally, but she's facing backwards.
Whereas if you try the thing
we were first thinking about,
It's unsettling.
Which is like,
let's just have her
literally walking backwards,
it kind of just looks like
a normal person walking backwards.
And all of a sudden
you're taken out of it.
Horror is difficult to do. As is comedy.
That's why there should
be more Oscar categories
for each of those,
because it is a challenging
art form to elicit
those type of responses.
You know? It's a lot
easier to make somebody cry
than it is to scare the
shit out of somebody
or to make them pee their pants laughing.
In my opinion,
speaking, generally, not specifically.
So Ben had to translate the script
in a way that would, okay.
This is how, these are the moments
where you've got to get
the scares and here's,
here's how we're going to go for that.
There's an added challenge of working
within the rules of TikTok
and it being one phone.
Yeah, literally shooting with a phone.
We could have taught ourselves
into each having a phone,
but that's not really how
we would conduct like the,
you know, writing a song
all night on, on, on TikTok.
The thing that we said we were doing,
we had to keep the conceit true, right?
So we had one phone filming vertically,
and then there's handoffs.
And there's, there's places
where you would stop filming.
And there's places where
you'd keep filming.
There's places where you'd
miraculously keep filming
while you were freaking out. It's like,
you got to take all
these things into account
to make it as real as possible.
Getting into those
details was so much fun.
As with Derek talking about the way
that he's going to export the songs so
that we can play them in
the room versus having
to add them in post.
So that there's proximity when you're,
when you're moving the phone around.
So if you listen with
headphones on, if you, you know,
that's a great way to rewatch Hazel
because of the amount of sound design,
because proximity and sound location is a,
is a big part of the story.
Yeah.
As is things like, um,
and you knew this when you wrote
it in the second scene, is that we've got
to establish the layout of the house
within the context of us
writing a song on TikTok
so that later, the viewer understands
where Hazel is coming from
and where she's taking me and taking you,
you have to understand
spatially what's going on...
Mhm.
So that you can, to set
you up to be scared.
So, so that you have expectations
when you're walking towards this door,
you should be the most scared.
Yeah.
As an example,
there's a lot of logistics and
details that go into getting
a certain response from an audience.
And again, that's what I can't wait
to see because in between clips, people,
hopefully, people will be
talking about it and making sense
of what's happening and
waiting for the next,
the next clip minutes, or...
Well, and, and...
10 minutes later.
My hope is, again,
it's very difficult to
be genuinely frightened
by something that you wrote.
Yeah.
Now, so my process is always, okay.
I, I don't like to see...
The first couple of
passes of the edit, right?
Like you, you, you were
working with Ben on that.
And I like to see it
once it's kind of like,
cause, I was like, I'm
very intimately sort of
like thinking about all this
during the writing process,
and then I kind of want
to separate myself from it
so I can be as much of an
audience member when I watch it.
But that was really hard to do.
I mean, when I watched the first cut,
there were moments where I
began to feel the sort of
frightened emotion that I
knew we were trying to go for.
Mhm.
But it's, it's just gonna be
so much different for somebody
who doesn't know what's,
what's going to happen.
Yeah.
Uh, and so that I'm
interested in that because.
That's the beauty of the conceit.
Is that it, we've set the stage for you
to be the most freaked out,
because it's not at all
what you're expecting.
It's kind of like when
I took Christy to see
Get Out and like, right
before the movie started,
she leaned over and she
was like, "Is this a,
is this movie scary? Or...
"Is it, is this a drunk?"
That's like, that's the
perfect way to go into a movie.
I was like, "I don't,
I don't think you should know.
You should just watch it."
Yeah. You didn't want her to,
yeah, get scared preemptively.
And, interesting dynamic.
You know, we, when we
were filming this thing,
like you said, we filmed over two nights.
The, the first night
we filmed in the woods.
And then the second night,
we filmed in the creative house and, uh...
We, we never do night shoots even,
I think on Buddy System, season one,
we did...
We did a night shoot.
We did one night shoot...
Maybe a couple.
Maybe, maybe a couple.
And, um, it's difficult for us. Like,
I was kinda nervous to like,
really like, okay, you know...
Well, your bedtimes 9:30.
The whole, the whole red bull
and that whole scene at the beginning.
We were really drinking the energy drink.
It's true.
I was drinking the hippo piss.
Or hippo, whatever it was.
Um, but you get into you're
out of there in the woods.
And, uh, it's hard to shoot at night
in the woods when you're like,
having to trudge a bunch of stuff,
um, a quarter of a mile down there.
Of course, the team did
most, most of the trudging,
I'll be honest.
It was, it was a lot
of fun to be out there
in the woods at night,
and to take a doorframe
and set that up.
Like, literally, that doorframe was there.
We didn't computer generate anything.
Most of the magic in the
cuts happened in swish pans.
Yeah.
But the biggest point of where
you walk down the hallway and go through
that middle doorway, and when you open it,
it's not the recording room
like we showed earlier,
but it's the, it's the forest.
Ben felt. And we agreed that, like,
we want to take a door
out there and we want
to do this practically.
And we don't want to, you know,
we frame the door close enough
so that it's already in the woods,
but you don't know it, because
of the way that he's lit it.
You open it up and then
there's the forest floor.
And it's all real.
Yeah.
Like, there's no,
there was no chicanery in post
to make that happen cause,
we built, like Paisley came out there
and they built the door frame.
Yeah, which, quick note about that.
Like, uh, everybody who
worked on this thing,
with the exception, exception of Paige,
was just, you know, a team, team member
here at mythical that was kinda stepping
into something that they don't always do.
I mean, Jenna was involved
on the production side,
Paisley built that,
built that door.
Which, she's always building
stuff for GMM, but it was...
Yeah.
And then of course, Ben
is kind of taking time
out of what he was doing
on Mythical Kitchen.
So, I think it was fun for us all
to kind of like get to do
something. I mean, it's fun.
Oh, yeah.
It's always fun for us to be like, hey,
this is something that's different.
And it, it like, it's,
it's not this giant thing
that we're throwing
ourselves in for, into,
for months and completely
turning our schedule upside down.
It's like, hey, this
is going to be a couple
of fun nights of working
together as a very small group.
I mean, I think we maximum had what,
like six people there at one time?
I think so. Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, just super.
Mission accomplished on that front.
Maybe eight people, it was, it was fun.
There was, someone was attacked
by a bat. Is that right?
Who was that?
It was, it just kept flying down.
It was like when Paige and I were,
when you all were filming without Paige.
Yeah. We left Paige and
Jenna back at the, um,
at the port-a-potty in the parking lot.
Well, we shot this at the same location.
And they were attacked by a bat.
We shot this at the same
location that we shot, the uh,
Monkey snake.
Which I don't remember
the name of that sketch.
Did You Get Me Anything?
Did You Get Me Anything.
So it was the, the,
the woods up in the Angeles,
Mount Angeles, national forest.
If you're into the
behind the scenes stuff,
Greg shot a bunch of behind the scenes.
Yeah, he did.
It's on the Mythical Society.
So, uh, you, you can, you
can see that visually,
but, um, there was a bobcat siting.
And it, I think we wrapped,
I think I got in bed that night at...
That morning.
5:00 AM.
Yeah.
Like in, I got,
maybe I got home a little
earlier than you guys.
And, but then the next night is when we,
we shot in the creative house.
We shot until sunup.
We shot everything else.
Yeah. We shot past sunup.
That was literally,
Yeah. We actually,
the last couple of shots,
we had to make sure
that the windows were not letting light in
because we were getting into the daylight.
Uh, you know, Stevie also
being there was very helpful.
I remember one instance
when we're shooting
at the, the creative house,
the first few scenes of like setting up
the farce of it being an interactive song,
writing thing, like the,
the first few scenes
where we're like supposed
to be totally ourselves.
And we don't want to give
any inkling that we're,
we're acting like the actor
versions of ourselves.
Mhm.
There's this weird thing
that happens that we,
we had to face, which was, we've got to,
we've got to be ourselves.
I mean, we've gotta be like
really in like vlog GMM mode.
And at some point, we're going
to be going off of a script
and we're going to be
making that transition
to still acting like
ourselves. But in this...
But now we're really acting.
We're doing something that
wouldn't happen to us.
Yeah, in this real word.
We're reacting to things
that wouldn't happen to us.
So, it's great to have,
like Stevie and Ben there, who are like,
"You need to play this scene,
like Rhett. You would respond to Lincoln
this way behind the desk at GMM.
And I don't feel like you're doing that."
Or, you have given me similar
direction where it was.
And I think that's a big test is if,
if people watch the first
few clips and they're like,
"Why are they acting weird?"
Then, we're a bit stuck.
I'm, I'm pretty confident
that, that I'm my main...
I feel good about it.
My main concern is that they're just,
most people are going to be like,
"I don't really care
about you guys bringing
me along the ride to write a song."
But I'm saying that from a
performance standpoint...
Yeah.
It was, it was a fun challenge
to think of it that way.
That we're making this
performance transition
from completely, or very loosely scripted,
to pretty tightly scripted.
Yeah, yeah.
So every aspect of it was, was
challenging in its own way.
That was part of why we
wanted to do it, you know,
just to like scratch those itches
and, uh, get the creative juices flowing.
And, we do think, I mean, I'll, I'll,
I'll say that I also have a secret hope
that, um, in the way that some of these
Twitter threads and whatever,
they might be.
Things that start kind of small on,
on the internet.
Like there is a world here to explore,
not necessarily, the exact
thing that we explored...
Mhm.
But the concept of the album
and being trapped in an album.
And it's been there forever.
Like, what's the origin story of that?
Like I would love,
I would love to be able
to tell that story,
not necessarily as a buddy
comedy with the two of us.
Who knows, but, so I
really hope people love it.
Now, one thing that
happened that just speak
to the nature of doing this on TikTok
and a platform that we're
learning is, you know,
we had this idea for this scene,
with the crow, where the
crow hits the, the door,
and then we go outside and
we see it and it's dead.
And there's a moment that we have
where that, it ends
with me throwing it away
and Link accusing me of littering.
And then, by the way, if you
look at the album closely,
like rewatch it and look at the album.
The album. Anytime the album is shown,
it's very intentional and yeah,
it will change, maybe in ways
that you did not anticipate
or see the first time.
But we were out there.
We had this, we had this replica crow.
It was, and we're out
there, gettin' ready to...
It seemed like it was
the weight of a crow.
Yeah.
It was very good.
And I'm out there,
and, so, putting this towel over it,
and that's when Greg, who was
doing the behind the scenes,
and also works on our social media
and knows more about TikTok than we do,
was he just kind of says in the moment,
he's like, "Yeah, I hope that,
that I hope that this part
of it is not misinterpreted
because, sometimes on
TikTok, if things are,
if people think that you're
doing something with the,
you know, it's conceivable
that if people thought
you were doing something
with actual dead animal,
that people would get upset,
and they could pull that video down."
Yeah. Is Rhett really throwing
a dead crow in the woods?
There was actually a, there was a scene,
so at that point we were like,
okay, well, what is scripted?
What you've planned to do.
And even when we shot test
footage of was you picking up
the crow and you making
fun of me for saying,
"I think it will come to
just give it a minute,"
and you pick it up and
you're, and I'm like,
"What are you doing?" You're like,
"Well, I'm going to give it a toss and see
if it'll..."
Give it a little headstart.
"Give it a little headstart on flying."
Give it, give it, a jumpstart,
like a paper airplane.
And you throw it. And it just
plops down on the concrete.
And it's hilarious.
Hilarious, very funny.
And then you pick it up again,
and that's when we talk
about the rotisserie chicken,
and you, you throw it in there.
You say test footage. I mean,
we shot that as a scene.
We have that intact,
which we are probably
showing to you right now.
What are you going to do with it?
I don't know.
Maybe it'll come back to, if
I give him a little jumpstart
like a paper airplane.
Nope.
Dude... He's fricking dead, man.
Okay.
I'm throwing him in the bushes.
Wh, what? Hold on,
wouldn't that be littering?
We're having a debate in the
moment of, is that too much?
Is throwing the crow and
having it plopped down people,
the risk of people
thinking it's a real crow
and getting upset, TikTok might
be flagging it, and, like,
if you remove this, this one
clip from the whole thing,
is that thing confusing and frustrating?
Yes, yes.
And it's like,
so we, you know, we're like, well,
let's just shoot another
version of this particular scene
where you don't plop it on the ground.
You just throw it in the woods
and maybe that'll mitigate
it, and we'll decide later.
So, but yeah, because
it's so experimental,
you get in your own head of like,
what is the thing that we're forgetting,
that's going to bring
this whole thing down?
And I remember, in that moment,
it was a bit of a crisis.
If that becomes the reason
that this doesn't work,
That sucks.
And so, yeah, so we,
so the toned down version
is in, is in there.
So, we're not concerned
about it at this point.
It's not, again, it's not as funny.
It's not as funny as me
throwing the crow up in the air
and having a hit the ground.
But again, for, that, that could be...
It's dead animal humor.
Maybe people don't like
that anyway, it wasn't,
it wasn't necessary.
So, you know, it's a matter of taste.
Yeah.
If not a matter of, uh,
like content restrictions and flagging.
Which we, got a reasonable
certainty that it wasn't.
But let's, let's skip to TikTok at large.
I think that, this is obviously
a strategy, but in parallel,
because we've been developing
Hazel for many months,
we're also trying to figure out,
what's our general TikTok
strategy because we're the,
the audience is over there is undeniable.
Yeah.
And so we made a decision.
Was it pre-pandemic?
Yeah. Cause we were in the boardroom.
I remember...
That's right.
I remember the moment. We
were all sitting together.
Are we gonna do TikTok?
Is Mythical going to be, are
we really going to try this?
Are we gonna, are we going
to allocate resources
to this when there's...
There's no money in it.
There's no direct revenue sharing?
Yeah.
Uh, so it's hard to justify from
a financial, business standpoint.
But from a strategic
standpoint, we said this,
I mean, this is not a flash in the pan.
This is happening.
Well, I specifically
remember thinking and saying,
I think, in that moment when
we were considering it, like,
I don't want this to be,
there are these moments in the birth
of social media platforms
in which your ability
to get traction like
right in the beginning,
like you remember all those
people like Ashton Kutcher,
how does he have so
many Twitter followers?
Huh.
Well, he got in and he took it seriously
from the beginning.
Now, if you're just like,
I think I'm going to get on Twitter,
like, getting a Twitter follower
these days and keeping it,
as someone who's been pretty much
the same number for a really,
really long time it's so hard.
This, at this stage in the platform.
But I was like, if we get in now,
even if the only thing we're doing,
because I think we said is,
let's just get on there.
And let's just put some
GMM clips on there.
Like, let's just have a
presence because getting
on there and letting people
know that you're there.
Even if you're not yet
doing anything strategic,
you're going to get
followers. And that worked.
And we got to a million
followers pretty quickly
and it was like, okay, good.
All right, we're, we a foothold here
on this thing that seems like
it's going to be important
in the, the larger sort of conversation.
But then it was like,
what are we actually going to do?
And me and you, in the
beginning of the pandemic,
cause I remember I was talking about this
uh, when we were doing our vlogs.
We actually started to
record for a potential vlog
on the Rhett and Link channel,
when we were doing those,
the process that we were coming up with,
because a lot of people were like,
what is happening on the Mythical TikTok?
Like, what are Rhett and Link doing?
Who's writing these TikToks?
Yeah.
So, we wanted to do a Rhett and Link vlog
where we talked about our
experimentation on TikTok
in documenting that
process. But then it became,
it became a lot to
figure out what we wanted
to try on TikTok personally.
And then to have to document it ourselves.
It just became a bit much. So.
But the thing that we have been doing,
that you may have noticed if you like,
if you've been watching
us for a really long time,
you may have picked up on this now. Yes,
there are a lot of things that
we sort of do as a company
that Link and I lend ourselves to
and kind of throw
ourselves into and you can,
and you might be like,
"I don't know if that's something
that Rhett and Link
would have come up with,
but I can see why they
did it," or, or whatever.
We threw ourselves into
TikTok on a very personal
like, level, and kind of went back to
that initial mentality of
the early days of YouTube
in which we were creators,
trying to figure out a new platform,
throwing things out there, experimenting,
throwing a lot of things at
the wall, getting reaction.
Now, that's not a full-time thing for us,
because of all the other stuff that we do.
But when we engaged with it
over the past year and a half or
so, that's how we would do it.
We would like, let's learn all we can.
And then the, the team
was also developing things
that we could, that Mythical
could try on our TikTok.
But what we were doing at
the creative house was like,
we were getting down on all
fours and filming each other...
As dogs.
As, as dogs or as these,
like strange superheroes
having a video conference.
Yeah, we were just trying
some character based stuff.
Trying things.
Uh, I can't remember what
else we tried, but then we...
Also just some straight up sketch stuff.
And a lot of this still is
on, some of it was taken down
because it just didn't do well.
A lot of it is still on
there from over a year ago.
That kind of fizzled out.
I think we got distracted
or pulled into other things,
and it didn't take off.
So it got a little,
it didn't really work.
It got disheartening.
Yeah.
And there were other
things that were working.
And then when we came back
to it, many months later,
we started doing some,
some sketch based stuff,
but we wanted to hone, and we're still
in the process of honing
what Mythical sketches,
what Rhett and Link sketches
on TikTok look and feel like.
And, so we're like, I would
want them to be conversational.
We don't him to, you know,
we don't, we, we learned,
we didn't want to go to prop
heavy or we didn't want to,
we wanted to be able to turn
these things out quickly.
We have to be super the engineer in us,
but also just the very busy people in us.
We have to be super efficient
with everything we do.
So, we really need to be able to shoot
one of these TikTok sketches in about,
you know, 15 or 20 minutes.
But it's shocking how
you can upload something
and it will get like thousands of views
and then you can upload something else
and it can get millions. If
not, tens of millions of views.
And they can be right next to each other
and no influence on one another.
So we're doing, right
now, we're doing sketches,
we're doing trends, TikTok trends.
And we're doing like GMM clips
that can be TikTokized.
Yeah.
So that, where they actually
work for that platform.
And don't feel just like an exported clip.
And as we record this right now,
like we've actually,
again, our team is great.
I don't want to mischaracterize,
when I say that we've
thrown ourselves into this.
I'm just saying that like,
we've really gotten involved
on the creative side,
but that doesn't mean
we're doing it all.
Our team is doing...
Right.
So much good work.
And at this point the
creative process is like,
we've got our internal
team pitching and writing.
We've got, we actually have
some, uh, outside writers
who make their own TikTok
that we like that are,
that are pitching and writing sketches.
We're pitching and writing
sketches ourselves.
And, and it's just become this sort of,
like old school collaborative.
Let's see what people respond to.
But, as of like right
now, as we record this,
we're getting some reaction.
Like we're, get, it feels like some people
are literally saying
things like you call it.
You guys are kind of finally getting
the hang of this platform.
When it was clear that
you were just kind of...
Mhm.
Trying a million different
things just a few months ago.
It's cool to read that. I mean, it, it,
it stings a little because it's like, hey,
you're reading our mail.
You know that like, but of course,
yeah, we're trying to figure this out,
but that's what we do as
individuals, as a duo,
as a company. What we do is we say,
"All right, what is the next thing?
How do we figure it out?"
And we gotta be willing to
get some egg on our face,
by the way, write that down.
I bet you there's something in that.
Like, a literal egg on the face.
Hah, that'll be hilarious.
Right, right. Mhm.
In order to learn something.
And, um, but yeah, there
was lots of, I mean,
the things that we would try
and when it doesn't work and
you can't understand why,
it's much easier to understand why,
to figure out why something does work,
than to figure out why
something didn't work.
You know?
And, this is a platform...
Even if you're wrong about the thing,
that why it worked,
you feel really certain why
it worked because it just,
the most plausible explanation.
I don't know, it tends to fall into place,
but then you're with the negative.
It's much harder to pinpoint it.
But it's so interesting
to be working in a,
in a platform that you don't know.
Like, we've learned
YouTube over the course of,
the time being on there.
So, we know in general, like, okay.
You can pitch us an idea
for a YouTube video,
and we can tell you, that's
probably not going to work.
And here's why, or that has a chance,
a good chance of working, and here's why.
Mhm.
The principles that go
into a TikTok video,
you know, title and thumbnail are so,
you know, strategic when it
comes to a YouTube video,
Mhm.
Because people are making a decision
in an environment where their
decision for the next video
is based exclusively
on title and thumbnail.
That's not how TikTok works, right?
TikTok works on people's reaction
to the beginning of the video.
Whatever happens in the
first 1, 2, 3 seconds
of the video is how they
determine if they're going
to keep watching that or swipe.
And then of course,
that data spread across
the bunches of people
who are watching that,
tell something to TikTok,
which then tells something
to, uh, the system and the,
for you page, which
determines if that video
is going to get shown to more people.
And that's why you can have
a video that literally has
11 million views
next to one that's got
a 100 thousand views.
On the same channel.
Or 50 thousand views.
Yeah.
Right next to each other,
which does not typically happen on YouTube
because people's habits are different.
It's a subconscious manipulation.
You're, you're not, typically
when you're scrolling,
you're not making an
active decision. It's this,
it's a passive decision
that you're hooked.
So you find yourself breaking your,
your scroll because something
peaked your interest.
It was something you read.
It was something that you,
you heard that gripped
you, that was irresistible.
Like you, um, and then is
that enough to keep you?
Is the hook set deep enough? And are we,
are we retaining your, your experience,
keeping you from like,
oh no, this isn't what,
this is not worthy of
me stopping scrolling.
Imma keep going.
All of that data is, is,
is scarily insightful.
But the way that we have to interpret,
it is just, did it work or
not? Did it halfway work?
There's a lot of speculation
about the algorithm,
but it, but it does.
The more that it's about human behavior,
the more that we feel like we can
do something about it,
right? And that's, that's,
that's what the algorithm
is trying to do too.
Decipher, decipher human behavior.
We're coming at it from,
from different angles.
That's a, it's, that's a fun challenge,
but when things don't work and
then they keep not working,
and maybe you've pre-shot a whole of these
that starts to get, uh, disheartening.
And there's also...
It's like, oh, we've made an
investment that now is it,
do we know it's, like, the next five
that we've already shot?
Do we know that none of
those are going to work?
Or is there a pivot we can do with text
or with something else within the tool to,
to make this still work?
Or to prove our, to prove
our theory wrong now
that like, we're going
down the wrong path.
Well, and there's the
challenge of not wanting
to fall into the trap,
which is a very difficult thing
not to do when you've turned
your creativity into a business.
And that is, to just become
reactive and try to find,
and then your only measure of success
is if people are watching it right now...
Right.
People have to watch it in order for us
to continue to feel like it's worth doing.
Even though there isn't really any money,
like occasionally it'll
be like a sponsorship deal
or whatever, but there's
not a lot of money in it.
Maybe there will be at
some point, but what that,
what that means is, and I
think to come back to the,
the Hazel thing for a second,
is it makes the Hazel project
for me that much more special because,
it really isn't a reaction to, oh,
people are definitely
going to click on this.
People are going to
care about this because
of what we've learned
about the way TikTok...
No.
Takes people's behavior into account.
It's more like, hey,
here's a cool platform,
that seems to be at a stage
where you can still experiment.
And it's not just,
you have to just do
this cookie cutter thing
in order to succeed.
Is this a place where we
can throw something up there
that nobody else is
doing in exactly this way
and see what happens? The who, again,
the platform isn't really made for
11 part series that
launch all in one night,
but is there something there
in this environment where it
can work to the degree where
it leads to something else
within that platform?
Could it be part of the platform,
even evolving and changing
and growing in what it's capable of?
Could it be that this
idea and this project
and just our, uh, moving forward with it
leads us to something else that
may or may not be on TikTok?
Mhm.
I don't know, but that's,
that's why we do things like that,
so that we, it, it, it's fun to do it,
and it's fun in the moment
and we're proud of it
and happy to do it,
but maybe it, it leads to
something even more interesting.
And when it comes to our
general TikTok strategy,
at this point, if we,
if we just wanted to do the
stuff that got the most views,
we would just chase the trends.
And... we,
you know, we, Greg would just
be pitching those things.
And every day we'd be like,
let's do the next thing,
but, we want to do other things as well.
Like, that's undeniably successful,
and it, it's fun and it's
engaging and it works.
And that, so that's
exciting and rewarding,
but we also want to express
ourselves as comedians.
And it is the place
where we can very quickly
stay in scripted...
Yeah.
And work on, work on our,
our character work and our acting and our,
our comedic timing and the, you know,
the, that craft...
Yeah.
And assert ourselves, uh,
on that front and say,
okay, part of Mythical's
brand, is this style of comedy.
Something that maybe we, you used,
you didn't know we used to do,
but here's a reminder or an education that
we still have this type of, uh,
comedic workup up our sleeves.
And now there's a place for
us to do it strategically.
I think that's, that's sort of the...
But we have to make it work.
Stars aligned in the moment.
Though, and it didn't end there,
the jury still out on...
We don't know exactly what
we're going to land on.
How the sketch is going to work, but.
But we do know...
We have gotten some that do work.
But we do know, with a few,
would maybe a few exceptions,
but no real big
exceptions, like, you know,
we started the Mythical Bits channel,
which is taking the short
form stuff that we're doing
for TikTok and Instagram,
and putting it on YouTube.
And, you know,
thank you to those of you
who are subscribed to that
and are enjoying the videos over there.
But I think it's plain to
see that YouTube is not
the place currently for
that type of content.
Like, it's not.
Or, maybe...
Maybe it will become...
Maybe, maybe it will be, I mean,
with mythical kitchen,
they were having similar conversations.
And then all of a sudden,
one of their shorts from months
earlier started to blow up.
Yeah.
I can't remember off the top
of my head, which one it was.
Yeah, I don't either, but yeah,
that's the whole short
strategy for YouTube.
YouTube is like, okay,
listen, this genre of video,
this vertical short video
is obviously working.
It's what the kids are into.
It's amazing...
They want to, they want to,
they want to capture
that audience as well.
It's amazing how you can come,
you can think you're
coming to a conclusion,
this isn't working. Do
we need to scrap it?
And then, when we were
talking specifically about
our scripted sketches on TikTok,
I mean, one one day, in the afternoon,
we were having a conversation about, like,
the amount of resources
we were putting into it,
and the amount of our time,
and the lackluster performance.
And then, as we were having
the business conversation
a few hours later,
we look on TikTok and the latest sketch
that we put up about, um,
the favor economy and the hot sauce,
like that one took off.
And, it changed the, our
conversation entirely,
because we were like, hold on,
we made a little tweak to
the text at the beginning
of this, and that, well,
maybe that unlocks it.
Well, to be specific,
We put text on-screen at the
beginning of the, the sketch.
And we had not been doing
that in the previous ones.
And I'm not saying that the sketch itself,
it doesn't stand on its
own and isn't relatable,
and that's why people like it, but,
I bet every dollar I've
ever seen that the decision
to put the text at the
beginning was the key
to getting it to break out...
Oh yeah.
Unlike the previous ones.
It was a discover...
And it's like, is that
really what it comes down to?
Like, people are scrolling
through TikTok...
Need to know what the sketch is about.
It needs a title...
In order to, yeah.
But well, not a title it needs, this is...
It needs context.
This is making fun of this.
If you're into that, stop scrolling.
Is basically the message we're sending.
So it's like, this is what
the joke is going to be,
which is kind of a hard thing to swallow.
Well, I would, you know, I would say,
this is the framework through
which you can enjoy the joke.
Yeah.
And if you're into the subject matter,
or what you think the subject matter is,
and now you know the
framework, you're on board.
You are now hooked.
Cause I, cause I shared with
you and some of our friends,
Dane, Dane Linda something,
like he's the guy who does
all the Southern dad stuff...
Yeah.
On, on TikTok. And this dude is,
I think he's in Louisiana.
He's super funny.
And his voice is perfect,
and his mannerisms.
And he has found this success in playing
this Southern dad character...
Yes.
Uh, and some other Southern characters,
but he's always just like,
Southern dads meeting
the neighbors, right?
Right.
Like he's, he's got that context through
which you can be like,
oh, this is the context.
These are the jokes within that context.
And that's just a, that's how TikTok
is working for a lot of people.
Now, there are some people like peteyusa,
who we talked about in our very
early episode about TikTok,
uh, who he's doing something that's just
so specific and so weird to what,
to who he is that you
begin to come to expect,
this is what a peteyusa TikTok is.
It's the, it's not relatable.
The relatable nature of
it is not why you're,
so, you don't need that contextualization.
It's just, you want to
kind of have a mind trip
with this guy whose mind
is going to go anywhere,
but where you think is going
to go, but for the most part.
And so we've tried some
of that, just like,
this is just plain weird.
But we just haven't
found as much success...
I think for that to work,
that has to kind of be
the only thing that...
You got to keep going to
the same exact well, yeah.
And we know we already
have three categories
of things we're doing.
Right. If all of a sudden
Petey started doing trends,
you would be like, dude, that's not cool.
You shouldn't, you shouldn't do trends.
You're cooler than the trends.
Yeah.
You, you, you have superseded the,
you know, transcended the trends.
Because of what, who you are.
It's amazing how precarious the,
the path forward is for these things.
And that, that's the world
that we've lived and breathed,
for years. I mean,
but it's, it's fresh with TikTok in that,
we're about like, we're
about to make that decision
to not do sketches anymore.
We didn't quite say that,
but we were about to,
and then the next day it's like, oh, we,
maybe we cracked it.
You know? And it, then it we're
shooting more and we have,
we have energy and where
we believe in it again.
So it's, it's a roller coaster ride.
And that's part of what we signed up for.
And then seeing in the
comments when something works
where, um, a lot of people say,
I started watching you when I was X age,
and now I'm Y age...
Yeah.
And it's like a 5, 7,
or 10 year gap between
those two numbers.
That's tremendously encouraging that we're
reminding and recapturing
an audience that, hey,
we're still here and we're here for you.
We're ready for you to
come back if you had,
if you'd fallen off
the, the Mythical wagon.
Yeah.
So, we remain very excited and engaged
in TikTok, uh, from day to day,
but, uh, hopefully it's
just onward and upward.
And I, and hopefully
this Hazel experience,
I, we'll always learn something,
and it will always be worthwhile,
but hopefully that's not in the context
of it just kind of flopping and being kind
of a speed bump in the story of Mythical.
Yeah, hopefully we don't
look at our TikTok,
you know, channel grid and see, oh man,
we've got these 11 videos in a row
that all happen in this one night.
And we completely like,
what if the story of this is that
we completely killed our TikTok,
and that we sent a message
to the algorithm by sending
so many videos up in one night...
Yeah.
That they decided that
no one cares anymore
about you guys.
And we never, ever again break
a million views on TikTok.
And this is going to be
this super ironic episode
of Ear Biscuits, in which
Rhett and Link's ambitions
completely backfired and undid everything
they had built on TikTok.
And then they just shut down their channel
and were never seen again.
It could happen.
Uh, and you know what, that's why this is,
that's why we did this.
It's a time capsule episode.
Yeah.
So, let us know what you think.
#Ear Biscuits.
I'm going to keep the wreck on topic here.
You just mentioned him.
Follow him on TikTok,
DANETHEGREATT with an extra T on the end,
he's only got 1.7
million followers, as of,
uh, you know, me reading this,
but the Southern dad
stuff he does is so great.
And then he's, he expands out to like,
Southern mechanic, AC repair
man. But the Southern mechanic,
if you drill back into
that, oh, that's great too.
But the dad is just amazing.
Southern school bus drivers be like...
If you grew up where we grow...
6.8 million views.
You, at the moment he goes
into his characteristics,
like, man, I knew so many people, is it?
Right.
This is an amalgamation of
so many people that we knew.
And, I can't even explain
how relatable it is.
Yeah. DANETHEGREATT with an extra T.
Hey Dane, we're big fans. Let's hang out.
You and your tattoos up
your neck and down ya arms.
Maybe we'll get some
neck tattoos with you.
Put that wig on and still becoming
I love it. Let's get a
neck tattoo together, Dane.
Okay, maybe you two can.
All right, well...
DANETHEGREATT.
We'll talk next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.